and I there'll be a lot of comparisons
like it's a little bit contact a little
bit close encounters a little bit make a
tree of life even but it is something
completely different
yeah it's its own thing and I think it's
okay to sort of draw comparisons because
we're all sort of influenced including
me as an actress and and I'm sure the
filmmakers buy things that have inspired
us in the past so yeah it is so unique
to itself I'm a huge fan of this movie
and all of Danny's films when I first
saw it it was something completely
unexpected and it's so intelligent and
it's got big concepts but it's got great
emotion as well did you have to think
about balancing the head part in the
heart part wow I guess that part sure I
definitely steer into the humor and the
things that are emotional and not really
lean on zeros and ones in the binary
yeah when the meds ultimately like when
you talk to the physicist about binaries
oh well this is actually the really
simplest form of communication one of
the great things about sci-fi but I love
is it just it feels like a chance to
talk about things that are happening in
the world you know and here there's so
many different themes you could you
could go with and so many conversation
starters what was interesting to you was
it about communication or maybe fear of
the unknown well I definitely the
communicative aspect of the film really
interest me and sort of how how to
approach communication like how would
one approach communication it's these
beautiful things that show us that
across cultures and language we have so
much in common language unites people
for you know but it also the things that
divide us it's a great conversation to
think about what does unite us all
that's a proper introduction